des questions on vous trouve l'info on
vous a souvent parlé du radon à la
facture le radon peut causer le cancer
du poumon des locataires nous ont écrit
et sont inquiets leurs propriétaires ne
pense pas toujours à tester le taux de
radon dans leur logement
nous sommes tombés sur un jugement
intéressant là dessus du tribunal
administratif du logement un couple dont
la femme était enceinte
au fait le test résultats 699 becquerels
par mètre cube d'air
c'est trois fois et demi la norme
acceptable de santé canada 200
becquerels leur test n'était pas
compliqué ils ont acheté un kit décédera
dont certifié par santé canada
ils ont installé le dosimètre ils
pouvaient le faire au rez-de-chaussée et
au sous-sol
parce que c'est là que se concentre le
radon et ils l'ont envoyé au laboratoire
après trois mois c'est lorsqu'ils ont
reçu les résultats qu'ils ont appris que
leur logement contenait un taux de radon
trop élevé à tel point que le tribunal
administratif du logement a estimé que
leur santé était menacée et que le
logement était impropre à l'habitation
le tribunal a mis fin à leur bail plus
de dix mois avant terme
en plus il a accordé aux couples 2000 $
en frais de déménagement une 1000 $ en
dommages moraux
ce jugement servez vous en pour
convaincre votre propriétaire de prendre
les mesures qui s'imposent
passés le mot